The Diagonalization argument comes up in
many contexts, and is very useful for
generating paradoxes and
mathematical contradictions.
To show how general the technique is,
let's examine it in the context
of English adjectives.
Here, I've created a table with English
adjectives both as the rows and
as the columns.
Consider the row to be the word itself,
and
the column to be the string
representation of the word.
For each entry,
I've written a 1 if the row adjective
applies to the column
representation of the word.
For instance, long is not a long word,
so I've written a 0.
Polysyllabic is a long word,
so I've written a 1.
French is not a French word,
it's an English word so
I've written a 0, and so forth.
So far we haven't run into any problems.
Now let's make the following definition,
a heterological word
is a word that expresses a property that
its representation does not possess.
We can add the representation of the
word to the table without any problems.
It is a long, polysyllabic,
non-French word.
But when we try to add the meaning
to the table, we run into problems.
Remember, a heterological word
is one that expresses a property
that its representation
does not possess.
Long is not a long word,
so it is heterological.
Polysyllabic is a polysyllabic word,
so it is not heterological.
French is not a French word,
so it is heterological.
In effect, we've taken the values
along this diagonal and
flipped them to create this row.
What about heterological, however?
If we say that this heterological,
causing us to put a 1 here,
then it applies to itself, so
it can't be heterological.
On the other hand, if we say that it is
not heterological, causing us to put a 0
here, then it doesn't apply to
itself and it is heterological.
So there really is no
satisfactory answer here.
Heterological is not well
defined as an adjective.
For English adjectives, we tend
simply to ignore the paradox, and
politely say that we can't
answer that question.
Even in mathematics, the polite response
was simply to ignore such questions
until around the turn
of the 20th century.
When philosophers began to look for
more solid logical foundations for
reasoning, and for
mathematics in particular.
Naively, one might think that a set
could be an arbitrary collection.
But what about the set of all sets
that do not contain themselves?
Is this set a member of itself or not?
This paradox posed by Bertrand Russell,
wasn't satisfactorily resolved until
the 1920s with the formulation
of what we now call Zermelo-Fraenkel
set theory or from mathematical logic.
Consider the statement,
This statement is false.
If this statement is true,
then it says that it's false, and
if the statement is false,
then it says so and should be true.
It turns out that falsehood,
in this sense,
isn't well-defined mathematically.
At this point, you've probably guessed
where this is going for this course.
We're going to apply the diagnalization
trick to turning machines.